help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
let's uh jump to the story here from
timcast.com oh yeah
governor kathy hokel to state's
republicans you are not new yorkers okay
if you are a republican living in new
york um
[Music]
who is that uh who's that uh republican
that we know who lives in new york frank
frank jonathan frank i'm just like i'm
just saying that because there's a bunch
okay it looks like naming eminence
there's other ones i know there's more
no
you mean quite frankly
yeah dude i love what's up right so uh
kathy hulkel's gotta go said republican
congressman and gubernatorial candidate
lee zeldin
just jump on a bus and head down to
florida where you belong okay whoa okay
bye
get out of town because you don't
represent our values wtf yeah
you are not new yorkers
wow there are like 5.4 million
registered republicans and like there
are probably independents who also lean
republican you guys should probably at
least get a plane ticket to florida
start seeing yourself out unelected
leader telling people ejecting people
like this is not good this is not an
american value man this is not something
we've ever really in my experience done
to our population before but it is
something that the nazis did to the jews
you don't repopulation was like an old
punishment you say the words
liberal international economy no
trafficking the two words dmt make
everyone take a shot
civil war yeah
you liked it
when the governor tells 5.4 million
people to get out of the state at a
rally for other political leaders dude
crap when the previous governor murdered
15 000 elderly people
i'm saying that
yeah there's a huge
one of the big criticism of this is like
do you not understand like we've already
lost a ton of people because of the
pandemic like that's our tax base
did you see
listen my friends
the other day we were talking about nate
silver he said liberal elites
pressured pfizer to with to hold back
the vaccine till after the election
i guess it was like to hurt trump or
something
that's what that's what nate silver was
saying
okay assuming that's true
these democrat politicians expected you
to die
in order to stop donald trump in fact
cuomo had the option to use that medical
ship which one was it it wasn't the
mercy
i thought it was but someone kept
telling me we were wrong oh i don't know
there was that big boat yeah there was
about and the javits center and cuomo
was like you know i could i'm gonna put
the sick people in the elderly home and
then 15 000 people died yep that took a
lot of voters out of the equation i'll
tell you that it's the uss comfort that
was the comfort of new york yeah yeah
there and ended 15 000 voters who are
older who tend to be conservative right
erased from the voting bloc older people
tend to vote republican and then we saw
it in what pennsylvania in michigan in
new jersey and in california yeah
that this is this is dark stuff this is
part of why uh top-down governance is
failing or at least struggling is
because it's like utilitarian they don't
cathy doesn't know all the republicans
that she's claiming are not new yorkers
that are like if she knew them
personally she probably wouldn't be
saying that well she always says like
i'm from buffalo i'm from upstate i know
about the rest of new yorkers like she
tries to present herself as more than
just like a politician who's catering to
new york city which dominates the
state's politics in a lot of ways but
like she is not i'd bring up the
economic criticism because the two major
issues for new york voters right now are
crime and the economy and right now she
says i don't care about the economy i
don't want any republicans here and
before she's running against lee zeldin
who has a remember uh someone tried to
stab him on stage and he correctly
predicted that person would be released
before morning and they and the attacker
was
i mean live in new york it doesn't make
any sense hold on i think she's right
she's like oh she said she said you got
to go what did you say jump on a bus and
head down to florida republicans in new
york i'm going to tell you just jump on
a bus and head down to florida yeah
florida florida needs you and florida's
great i say stay and fight though maybe
she's going to start busting them down
the way that like abbott's busting
illegal immigrants to dc like she's
gonna get her own system going but you
saw that story that they're not even
making it right they're
yeah it's just you think it's better to
stay in new york and change it from the
inside i've had the opinion for a long
time it's what their what blue team
seems to be doing is forcing people to
retreat and i've always had the opinion
of the more you retreat eventually
you're going to find your back to a
cliff and then they're going to force
you to jump or do a desperate move to
make a mistake
i know a bunch of new yorkers because i
live really close to it and the idea of
um how do i put this they will never
forget like say you had an older family
member in the hospital or something like
that you weren't allowed to visit them
or
you had one you could only have one
person visiting at a time
that is how you can flip most
demographics red for sure nobody's going
to ever forget that at least from our
generation so not being able to visit an
elderly family member god forbid you had
someone that died
those people will never vote blue again
probably
so when she says leave she's trying to
force them to retreat because she knows
she's already lost them so don't leave
in fact stay in place i know i've known
a bunch of new yorkers who they're
always talking about is it time to go is
it time to go i say no you should
reclaim your land you should not say
i'm going to go somewhere else where i
can be happy
blue team's strategy seems to be to try
to make you run away
it's like a paper tiger kind of thing
you've already lost the fight you may as
well not fight now because you've lost
but actually there's way more of you
than you think especially in new york
state here's the thing too if every
single
uh
if every single republican in aoc's
district actually voted republican right
they would win they think that by
it's like oh i'm going to lose anyway so
i may as well not vote that's probably
what it is
i don't think even a lot of people know
that there's an election coming up in
the next few months but it's uh who who
just uh uh won the republican nomination
tina something in new york in aoc's
district uh i can look yeah look i'm
because i'm i'm drawing a blank on the
name but um
she has a real thick accent it's it's
like i think it's it's what two to one
or three no it's like it's like three to
one democrat to republican in her just
in her district it's like d plus 25 or
something but if you look at the amount
of people that actually turn out it's
really really low tina forte is that her
name yeah four days edit four to four
times cause they don't realize how
important it is but but i will be
realistic you would need every single
republican
and conservative leaning person
every single one grandma and then you
need to also hope the democrats don't
turn out the democrats typically don't
turn out like aoc i think got like 100
and something thousand out in a district
of 750 000.
if every conservative voted it would it
would be the weirdest thing ever they'd
be like how did new york 14 flip
republican it's like because the
republicans got fed up and they actually
went out and voted i think a lot of
those votes though are people who are
they've been dead for a while maybe now
this is just my opinion i'm not saying
the f word but a lot of those people
like you know they recycle social
security numbers and stuff that's an
easy out
that's an issue there's a lot of
corruption in new york sure sure sure
i'm all in favor of cleaning up voter
rolls but i think it's such
what i don't like is that in 2016
they screamed for years that russia
hacked the machines and all that stuff
and then to see the right start using
that narrative and i'm like bro even if
it's the case you need to talk there's
two big things you need to do one rally
everyone you know to go and vote and two
make sure you're paying attention to the
process sure like in wisconsin they're
saying those drop boxes are illegal but
when you come out and you say stuff like
that it's like a defeatist mentality no
no
in fact we should overwhelm i say we as
if i'm on red team necessarily i like
them but we should go in overwhelming
numbers so even if someone were to cheat
which never happens
they can't win because the numbers are
going to be so overwhelmingly on your
side here's here's what i think is
important when it comes to politics
if you're not cheating you're not
trying there's no such th the whole the
whole game is fight for power by any
means necessary now there are certain
parameters where things are flexible
albeit a moral or wrong and then there
are certain parameters where you're
outright committing criminal activity
proving criminal activity is very very
difficult and rarely happens it happens
sometimes desantis just found a bunch of
people who weren't eligible to vote were
voting and things like that
so when people come out and they assert
that the reason we lost is specifically
because of criminal activity it's like
or are you just not paying attention to
the fact that the rules were adjusted in
such a way that it harmed you and your
ideology pennsylvania is the best
example they changed the rules a year in
advance they cut a deal with republicans
to expand universal mail-in voting which
deeply hurts republican areas and deeply
benefits blue areas
pay attention to those things
but i don't i just
we've got to maintain that um that we're
going to win mentality and not not be
too focused on sure i definitely don't
want to reinforce the idea that we may
as well not bother because they're going
to cheat i still think
red team can overwhelmingly win just by
convincing family members say you got
people at church that
don't vote because they just don't want
to or maybe they're lazy or something
just convince them how important it is
and they already know how important here
here's the other issue i have like if
you think
they are cheating why aren't the other
side why isn't the other side cheating
like why is it only ever though this
like you're the opponents of your person
i just want lots of accountability those
are awesome by the way the green tea
these yeah i got a story to tell you
about this later
i know i love these they're sugar free
and they're super good for me yeah you
know anyway anyway i'll tell you later
you know it's it's it's always like the
other side is cheating and it's just
like
if you think the establishment
republicans aren't playing games you
know what i mean it's it's one big
political machine right that's what i'm
that's what i'm saying i would love
accountability on both sides yeah
especially with the machines themselves
right now we've got paper man i would
love it or or at least digital machines
with transparent algorithms so that we
can watch the counts happen in real time
and then you can verify your vote and as
opposed to what they did and what they
have been doing is that they were
tallying them in back rooms with
proprietary software code yeah so we
can't verify that the votes are even
being tallied properly the first
verification
ian you are completely correct the first
thing that we need to do is open source
publicly accessible source code on all
of our voting equipment why not or a
switch to paper ballots or something or
both yeah or both yeah yep yep yep i
think a three step like a three barriers
would be so you have your paper you have
your digital machine thing and then you
have a blockchain tally as well we're
relatively young in that we understand
what it means to say open source but how
do we convince people in like the
legislative branches what this means and
why it's important i don't think public
accountability
public accountability systems i've got
private companies controlling our
elections is a conflict of interest yeah
um i think they would all get that i
mean these are all words that they were
familiar with
universal
voting
access
sure voter transparency i want to point
you guys at a video of a testimony a guy
gave in front of congress if you want to
say what can we do with congress about
building an algorithm in a voting
machine that changes the vote 5149 oh
yeah and that no one unless you have the
source code you wouldn't know that it's
doing it or unless you could uh run it
up against
the uh
the actual paper ballots you wouldn't
know that anyone's doing it that's his
testimony it's like when you ask them
how do we know it's secure it's hashtag
trust me bro yeah it really is yeah and
he
his testimony said that in the year 2000
he built this foreign ohio
uh was it a senator i should be able to
have this this thing bookmarked this
testimony bookmarked it's on youtube
i'll pull it up within a minute i think
one of the most striking things about
this is that she's so i mean i think we
have this idea that like when people get
to the you know she won her democratic
primary uh that they'll start trying to
court the independent vote and move to a
more moderate position but with this
cultural is just like blatantly going
farther left she is trying to completely
activate only democratic voters and
that is fascinating to me she thinks she
can win on complete liberal rage alone
we need we need to activate nuclear dark
ultra maga yeah this is the testimony
that people need to see it's eugene uh
the video on youtube if you want to
watch it's called american election
hacker testifies and it's from i don't
know 10 years ago or something but uh
the guy's name is clinton eugene curtis
he testified under oath in front of the
u.s house judiciary members in ohio that
tom feeney in the year 2000 had him
build a prototype software package that
would secretly rig an election to sway
the result 5149 to a specified side
under oath testimony that he built that
for uh tom feeney
i was at um i've gone to a whole bunch
of the def con conferences and they have
like they have a voting hacker village
or something like that where they have a
bunch of different voting machines and
they're all just having a good time
breaking into them
so open source can help solve a lot of
that because it allows the public to
scrutinize how the system is being
operated that's that's really important
right now the voting machines can't
handshake with some machine remotely a
million miles away yeah they can't have
it so that you can't it doesn't connect
to anything outside
like
um that would be nice too but like so
with a proprietary software voting
machine you could have like 100 people
vote and the machine's like
if
the vote is this then subtract 10 from
side a and so it there will be a thing
but if you don't have the code to see
the math of what it's telling you what
to subtract and what to add you wouldn't
know that it's moving the votes but if
you can see the code then you'll see oh
there's something telling the machine to
subtract 10 if that's not right it
shouldn't be doing that it should just
be doing an honest tally
that's where we say accountability like
honestly this kind of code i'm not like
an expert by any means and you know way
more than me but i'm sure like most
amateur coders know how to tally things
this is not difficult it's it's trying
to uh account for all the uh weird
things like what if i i scan a vote and
it doesn't go through and then we have
to scan it again does it delete the
original scan
should should the ballots have like
should they should they be serialized so
that there can't be repeats you know
what i mean yeah
i mean these are real like easy
questions bitcoin could solve this
crypto crypto could solve this
if if uh we've talked about crypto
voting but if we just do like a
hybridized system where
when you vote
your your you know ballot has a has a
cryptographic association with your name
and your registration then you can't you
don't got to worry about them going
through the machine twice or anything
like that it's like you know rejected
already in the system thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you